[Musique]
bon sang je skie bonsoir à toutes et à
tous et bienvenue dans cette édition
spéciale de la rédaction de tv 78
enregistré ici au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines nous sommes le
jeudi 28 avril voici les titres
[Musique]
la tournée des sites olympiques de paris
2024 de passage dans le département le
président du comité d'organisation tony
estanguet était ce jeudi au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
qui accueillera les épreuves de cyclisme
sur piste et de pentathlon moderne
l'occasion de faire le point à j moins
820 de l'événement avec plusieurs sites
des jo dans l'agglomération saint
quentin en yvelines est à la recherche
de ses bénévoles 1000 places sont
réservées pour les habitants du
territoire il en reste encore
quelques-unes comment être candidats
quels sont les critères de sélection
éléments de réponse et puis dans cette
émission direction également saint
germain en laye la ville sera le camp de
base des athlètes de la team grande
bretagne pour les jeux olympiques de
2024 le partenariat a été officialisé
cet après midi au cours d'une cérémonie
ce jeudi le vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines installé à
montigny le bretonneux accueillait donc
cette journée une journée presse à
l'occasion de la venue sur place du
comité d'organisation de paris 2024 dans
huit cent vingt jours très exactement la
france accueillera les jeux olympiques
et aussi les jeux paralympiques avec ici
au vélodrome les épreuves de cyclisme
sur piste de paracyclisme sur piste et
aussi du pentathlon moderne pour les
scream au programme de cette matinée
visite des lieux mais aussi baptême de
cyclisme sur piste et parmi la
délégation pour l'amener justement tony
estanguet bonjour a tenu bon jour triple
champion d'europe triple champion du
monde et triple champion olympique vous
connaissez justement cette échéance
olympique et vous l'amener maintenant en
tant que président du comité
d'organisation de paris 2024 vous
hésitez régulièrement laissez vous étiez
déjà venu ici sur ce vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines est là
aujourd'hui c'est le début de la tournée
des sites olympiques c'est ça pourquoi
elle a démarré ici c'est un symbole
assez fort de commencer la tournée des
sites de paris du 24 ici au vélodrome
nationale vous savez le vélodrome
nationale c'est un peu la fierté du
sport français c'est l'un des fleurons
c'est un équipement incroyable qui allie
à la fois le sport de très haut niveau
mais aussi comme aujourd'hui des moments
d'initiation de pratique ouvert à tous
c'est un peu ça l'esprit de paris 2024
on veut que les athlètes français soient
dans les meilleures conditions on veut
qu'il gagne un maximum de médailles on a
envie que les françaises et les français
les soutiennent soit derrière eux il n'y
a rien de mieux que d'essayer un sport
pour être ensuite conquis et d'avoir
vraiment envie de soutenir ces athlètes
l'a donc aujourd'hui c'est une première
étape importante pour nous et on est
ravi d'être ici avec les plus grands
champions français en plus avec pour
objectif de visiter les lieux et vous
allez faire un petit baptême de cyclisme
sur piste vous avez peut-être déjà testé
à y paraît il paraît qu'ils m'ont
réservé cette surprise mais là ça serait
bien qu'ils aient pas les caméras s'il
vous plaît déplacement dans les yvelines
on le sait où il ya de nombreux sites
olympiques on a parlé de ce vélodrome
national de 50 en ligne aussi les
épreuves de goal de l'été et et de bmx
qui se dérouleront dans les yvelines
l'équitation également pourquoi cet
attrait pour les yvelines qu'est-ce qui
est en fait un département intéressant
pour organiser ces épreuves de paris
2024 que depuis le début de l' aventure
pareille 1024 les yvelines se sont
mobilisés ont montré leur enthousiasme
leur envie de faire partie de l'aventuré
on a tout de suite
réussi à avoir des bonnes connexions à
s'entendre parler le même langage à
avoir cette envie de d'un côté continuer
à accompagner le développement sportif
dans ce territoire qui aime le sport et
donc voilà du coup vu qu'ils sont
moteurs on est moteur et on fait plein
de projets ensemble et du coup ça
profite à la population comme comme
aujourd'hui par exemple avec peut-être
d'autres épreuves dont parle du cyclisme
sur route aussi avec un tracé dans les
yvelines a été évoqué aussi un temps le
marathon pour tout ce qui pourrait
passer par verser on pourrait voir de
nouvelles épreuves dans les yvelines qui
ne sont pas encore annoncés exactement
en fait tout n'est pas encore
complètement finalisé et les yvelines
étant vraiment un territoire très moteur
ben il ya de grandes chances qu'on
continue à travailler avec les yvelines
parce qu'encore une fois je pense qu'on
partage le même adn et on a vraiment
envie de réussir ces jeux d'exception en
2024 et notamment grâce aux divines on
est à j moins 800 d'en parler de jeu
d'exception c'est qui aura déjà une
cérémonie d'ouverture unique jamais vu
qui sera en extérieur à l'extérieur d'un
stade sur la scène l'objectif de ces géo
quelle trace vous voulez laisser dans
l'histoire on a envie que sais je fasse
la fierté de notre pays c'est un moment
d'optimisme c'est un moment d'espoir
c'est un moment d'humanité ou si on va
accueillir le monde dans notre pays on
veut que les gens vivent des jeux
spectaculaires parce que c'est d'abord
des émotions qui doivent rester mais on
veut aussi que ces jeux soient
participatif qui soit très ouvert qu on
ne résume pas cette aventure à quelques
jours de compétition mais que ce soit
pendant plusieurs années la possibilité
de renforcer la place du sport dans le
quotidien des français parce que voilà
nous on pense que dans ce pays si on
investit un petit peu plus dans le sport
on va répondre aussi à des enjeux de
santé des enjeux de lien social les
enjeux de l'éducation des enjeux
écologiques parce que voilà pratiquer le
vélo par exemple c'est aussi un bon
moyen de transport et donc il ya plein
de dangereux aujourd'hui autour de la
pratique sportive et les jeux olympiques
et paralympiques doivent être un levier
justement une contribution à notre
société dernière question tournée qui
débute aujourd'hui au vélodrome vous
allez revenir dans les yvelines
prochainement à je n'en doute pas je
n'en doute pas et ce sera toujours avec
beaucoup de plaisir parce que encore une
fois on n'est vraiment pas loin et on
est toujours très bien accueillis ici
c'est un territoire romand sportif qui
aime le sport et on a plein de choses à
faire ensemble merci tony estanguet nos
deux rappels président du comité
d'organisation de paris 2024 qu'on a
évoqué justement quelques-uns des sites
yvelinois qui vont accueillir
les épreuves de djo de paris je vous
propose un tir un petit tour d'horizon à
saint quentin en yvelines et c'est avec
nicolas landry
[Musique]
avec ses nombreux sites l'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines se prépare
à recevoir cet événement recevoir les
épreuves et les athlètes on rappelle les
dates 26 juillet 11 août pour les jeux
olympiques et ce sera du 28 août au 8
septembre pour les jeux paralympiques
avec moi jean michel fourgous bonjour
bonjour résidant de saint quentin en
yvelines tournée des sites olympiques
qui démarre aujourd'hui à saint quentin
en yvelines au vélodrome qu'est ce que
ce qu'est ce que ça vous fait justement
de voir cette tournée quand même un
événement phare avant avant ces jo
démarré ici dans l'agglomération eh bien
on sait que ce vélodrome nationale et de
vue effectivement une sorte de totem je
pense en france avec dans de très gros
événement sportif et que le fait qu'on
ait retenu pour les jeux olympiques bien
sûr le fait aussi le vaccinodromes qui a
fait le tour du monde c'était un peu la
référence nationale sur 1800 centres de
vaccination et trois fois et premier
prix bon donc bien sûr ils puissent se
développer le sentiment d'appartenance
au cid et de tous les gens de saint
quentin qui ont beaucoup utilisé aussi
dans ses problèmes aussi de sanitaires
donc j'irai beaucoup d'événements
prestigieux
bien entendu on est tous très fiers de
cela bien qu'il y ait même le golf
national aussi à la colline d'elancourt
que la colline la plus élevée d'île de
france il ya plein de vie sur de très
belles choses et puis en même temps on
est fiers parce que c'est toutes les
valeurs que auxquelles on croit que l'on
veut promouvoir et puis on est dans
paris saclay qui est un peu un
territoire d'innovation comme vous le
savez et ça va être l'occasion bien sûr
de de faire bouger les choses bouger les
lignes de faire avancer les gens il ya
des gens qui cherchent du sens à la vie
on veut faire de ces événements puisque
on a plusieurs sites vraiment quelque
chose qui redonne du sens à la vie à
avoir un projet à faire des efforts
faits toutes les valeurs qu'on ait
décliné voilà donc c'est formidable
merci jean michel fourgous
et à présent je suis avec laurent
mazaury vice président aux sports et aux
jo à saint-quentin-en-yvelines bonjour
bonjour on a parlé donc de ces sites
olympiques ici la tournée démarre cette
tournée olympique au vélodrome national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines on sait
qu'il ya aussi des événements qui vont
arriver notamment les championnats du
monde de cyclisme sur piste qui
reviennent au vélodrome c'est ce sur ce
genre d'évènements que vous comptez vous
préparez aussi pour l'échéance olympique
alors vous avez raison c'est à la fois
un test mais en même temps c'est presque
une répétition puisque ça quand on y est
habitué aux grands événements sportifs
et nous avons déjà accueilli des
championnats du monde avec tout le
succès que l'on sait puisque c'est un
des rares moments où le vélodrome est
plein avec celui également de la finale
la coupe du monde de football qu'on
avait donné en direct ici et donc on
attend avec impatience cet événement
mais on n'a pas besoin de répétition on
est déjà au top avec d'autres sites bien
sûr à saint quentin en yvelines on pense
aussi à la colline qui va accueillir les
épreuves de vtt il ya un grand projet
aussi autour de ce site c'est de lui
donner un futur et de l'ouvrir aux
habitants après cjo plusieurs phases
avant le début des travaux il ya une
concertation à l'automne et jusqu'au 20
mai les habitants peuvent de nouveau
donner leur avis dans une procédure de
participation publique par voie
électronique c'est pourquoi faire
concrètement comment comment ça se passe
cette participation alors d'abord la
réglementation oblige effectivement à
cette consultation et puis on est très
heureux de la réaliser elle permet
effectivement que chacun donne son avis
sur le projet lié aux jeux olympiques
attention ne confondons pas la partie
héritage du futur et 7 et viola on est
vraiment sur le projet olympique les
différents aménagements qui sont prévues
savoir ce que les riverains et les
habitants veulent comment ils veulent le
vivre comment ils veulent pouvoir
habiter à côté pendant les épreuves
comment ils veulent également anticipé
la phase de chantier puisque la phase
chantier a lieu en amont mais elle
aurait également lieu en aval après
région puisqu'elle courra jusqu'en 2025
pour toutes les compensations
écologiques et l'idée m'est assez
d'écouter les habitants et bien entendu
de prendre en compte l'ensemble de la
réaction dans les travaux d'aménagement
et dans la façon dont ces travaux sont
eux mêmes réalisé début des travaux
d'ici la fin de l'année c'est toujours
l'objectif à la fin de l'année 2022 tout
à fait avec les premiers travaux de
protection du site qui devrait avoir
avoir lieu à partir de la rentrée
septembre et puis ensuite on attaque la
soli deo puisque c'est elle qui prend
les clefs du lieu pour pouvoir réaliser
la maîtrise d'oeuvre et piloter
l'ensemble du chantier on attaque les
différents aménagements dans un premier
temps la suppression de tout ce qui pose
problème sur le site encore une fois en
matière écologique puisque nous avons
des espèces invasives dont la célèbre
renouée du japon qui pose de gros
problèmes et qui ne sera qu israël
supprimés et qui sera compensée
écologiquement à la fin et puis la
réalisation des pistes et toutes les
zones d'accueil pour les délégations
internationales le public et aussi la
presse dont vous faites partie il ya
aussi un autre site on revient ici au
vélodrome juste à côté c'est cette piste
de bmx le stadium de bmx alors il ya il
y avait une incertitude la dernière fois
qu'on vous avait reçu en plateau pour
parler des jo sur le site qui allait
accueillir justement cette piste de bmx
il était question de l'île de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines et vous nous
aviez parlé de rapatrier sur le stadium
existant avec peut-être la possibilité
d'enlever le toit pour des raisons de
diffusion télévisée est ce que c'est
tranché aujourd'hui alors oui c'est
réglé les seaux pelles et les épreuves
de bmx resteront au vélodrome et donc
sur le site du bmx juste à côté du vélo
du vélodrome quelques aménagements
secondaire en termes de piste vous savez
que la réglementation du sport du bmx
est un petit peu particulier puisque les
pistes évolué à au fur et à mesure que
les prestations qualitatif des champions
évolué on rajoute des petites
difficultés on modifie un peu les
virages et le toit a priori à l'heure où
je vous parle restera en place on a
trouvé des solutions avec la partie
télévisuelle n'y aura pas de travaux de
suppression du toit à ce stade dans ce
cas il en parle avec tony estanguet a
priori peut être si la possibilité de
voir une autre épreuve arriver à 50 en
une le cyclisme sur route est ce que on
pourrait voir l'épreuve passée par les
routes saint-quentinoise écoutez c'est
un secret mais de polichinelle oui en
effet et alors c'est extraordinaire nous
aurons les épreuves de cyclisme sur
route qui passeront d'ailleurs au pied
du vélodrome et qui traverse une grande
partie de 50 ans divine à la fois les
épreuves masculines mais également les
autres effets minimes et pourquoi cette
extraordinaire c'est parce que du coup
ce sera la seule épreuve des jeux
olympiques à laquelle sur saint quentin
en yvelines on pourra citer sans
billetterie est donc ouvert au plus
grand nombre on est parti comme en
heureux que les épreuves de cyclisme sur
route passe à saint quentin pour toute
la population et nous mêmes on pourra
voir une belle épreuve et d'ici 2024 on
imagine l'agglomération qui s'est mise
et jean mode 2024 qui va voir arriver
cet événement avec des temps forts on
pense forcément la journée olympique
auprès des scolaires ce qu'il ya un
travail auprès des scolaires la
génération 2024 c'est quoi la les temps
forts cette année et dans les mois à
venir alors vous avez raison chaque
année on a notre journée olympique mais
nous avons les champs et je voudrais il
le rappeler les championnats de cyclisme
sur route mondiaux ont lieu ici
également l'open de france et également
les championnats du monde de golf
amateur alors ça peut paraître un détail
contre parle de golf amateur mais ces
deux ses jambières du monde là que
sortent les grands champions de demain
tiger woods typiquement est issu des
championnats du monde de golf amateur
d'envoyer tout s'est tu cette mixité
entre le sport amateur le sport
professionnel et le sport de très haut
niveau c'est à saint quentin en yvelines
et c'est pour préparer l'accueil des
jeux olympiques merci laurent mazaury
vice-président sports et aux jo pour
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines à l'occasion de ces jeux
olympiques d'ailleurs laurent mazaury
les collectivités concernées recherchent
leurs futurs bénévoles c'est un maillon
essentiel on le sert pour l'organisation
d'un tel événement c'est le cas de saint
quentin en yvelines comment candidate et
quels sont les critères de sélection les
précisions dans ce sujet de patrick
jacques de dixmude et de mathilde franco
terre de ge paris 2024 saint quentin en
yvelines se prépare à accueillir les jo
avec cinq épreuves sur son territoire
l'agglomération s'est lancé dans une
recherche active de bénévoles l'idée
c'est que tout le monde peut être
bénévole dès lors qu'il a plus de 18 ans
pour être exact qu'il aura plus de 18
ans le 1er janvier 2000 24 que la
personne en question par le français et
où l'anglais ça aussi c'est une mode de
sélection bien entendu que la personne
soit bien entendu disponible pendant la
période des jeux olympiques mais
également paralympiques puis ensuite
nous l'inscrivons sur un certain nombre
d'événements tests qui permettront de
lui montrer à la fois ce que l'on
attendait de voir celle en adéquation
avec les différents rôles que l'on pu le
confier le comité d'organisation des
jeux olympiques paris 2024 à réserver
1000 places pour les habitants de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines les volontaires auront pour
mission d'accueillir les spectateurs les
athlètes les journalistes ou encore
d'aider à l'organisation aux transports
ou aux services médicaux jean paul s'est
porté volontaire pour lui c'était
évident parce que je suis un ancien
sportif et que aujourd'hui je ne peux
plus pratiqués pour des raisons diverses
et variées et que j'ai envie d'aider le
monde sportif
j'ai envie d'aider les jeunes survie de
promouvoir
bac tout cet esprit sportif que j'ai
entretenu tout m'a dit j'aimerais bien
avoir une belle épreuve à l'intérieur du
vélodrome mais bon si je suis pas choisi
ben j'accepterai quand même c'est ça la
mentalité du bénévole pas de date limite
les inscriptions se termineront quand le
chiffre des 1000 bénévoles sera attend
cependant ne tardez pas car il reste 300
places de son côté la ville de montigny
le bretonneux a aussi décidé de
s'impliquer dans la recherche de
volontaires la commune s'est fixé pour
objectif de recruter 3 130 bénévoles
[Musique]
et
le passage de la délégation de paris
2024 ici au vélodrome était aussi
l'occasion d'autres animations il ya eu
des baptêmes de cyclisme sur piste mais
également des rencontres avec les
personnalités sportives je vous propose
d'écouter quelques réactions
journée ça représente beaucoup de
partage de découverte c'est juste en
fait montrer au grand public ce que
c'est le cyclisme sur piste et quand on
voit il a avec une certaine appréhension
et qui repartent avec le sourire je
pense que la mission est remplie c'est
une journée importante parce que je
pense que cette opération de promotion
des sites olympiques est entamée par le
cojo va avoir une forte portée auprès de
tous les passionnés de sport en france
et c'est très important pour nous que ça
démarre par le cyclisme est ici plus
particulièrement à saint quentin par le
lieu où nos athlètes travaillent en
permanence à préparer les grandes
performances qu'on attend d'eux nos
équipes nos athlètes sont déjà dedans
puisque les compétitions commencent et
nous allons nous sommes à quelques jours
de leur entrée dans la qualification
olympique donc nos staff nos entraîneurs
nos athlètes des pistards les courants
de bmx vtt de route sont son oms a en
tête c'est ce qui au quotidien les
animes de travail et de répéter de
progresser avec l'objectif de débrayer
ici lors des jeux de paris on cite à
présent ce vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines car cette
journée du jeudi 28 avril était
résolument olympique à
saint-germain-en-laye un partenariat
entre la ville et la ti une grande
bretagne a été officialisé pour les jeux
olympiques cet après midi sur place
michael et demi d'euros
les jeux olympiques de paris 2024 se
prépare déjà ici à saint germain en laye
à cet officiel la ville a signé ce jeudi
à 28 avril 2022 un partenariat avec le
comité olympique britannique et son
président yves jung robertson ce qui
signifie que la team gb viendra donc
s'entraîner ici dans la ville yves
binois cependant le rendez vous parisien
la délégation qui compte en général
entre 350 et 400 sportifs s'entraînera
au stade georges lefèvre au camp des
loges 80% des disciplines devrait
pouvoir s'exercer sur ce site on pense
notamment au tennis avec les cours déjà
présent au football avec les terrains
utilisés par l'équipe du paris saint
germain il ya également la piste
d'athlétisme et le stade de rugby
utilisé par l'équipe locale du mlsgp ou
encore le hockey sur gazon la ville
excellent dans ce sport et peut compter
sur les terrains flambant neufs j'ai cru
apercevoir également des installations
pour s'entraîner au beach volley au fond
du stade georges lefèvre pour la ville
de saint germain en laye c'est donc un
très gros morceau la délégation
britannique termine régulièrement haut
du tableau final des médailles à tokyo
la team un grande bretagne avait terminé
quatrième avec 65 médailles le maire de
la commune arnaud péricard s'est donc
félicité évidemment de ce partenariat il
ya quelques instants au total plusieurs
centaines d'athlètes sont attendus sur
le site de saint germain en laye à
partir du printemps 2024 pour les stages
ils seront présents jusqu'à l'été et
l'ouverture à des jeux olympiques et
bien sûr ils seront présents aussi
pendant les épreuves
avant de refermer cette édition les
autres informations à retenir dans les
yvelines de cette journée du jeudi à 28
avril l'actualité résumé par mathilde
autres
dans le reste de l'actualité yvelinoise
de nouveaux radars ont été installés sur
l'a12 au niveau de saint cyr l'école le
premier se situe à l'entrée du tunnel de
fontenay-le-fleury en direction de
trappes le second à sa sortie vers paris
s'ils ne sont pas encore en marche
attention aux excès de vitesse dans les
prochains jours cette portion est
limitée à 110 km heure le digitroc fait
escale à maurepas jusqu'à samedi 30
avril ce camion itinérant propose des
formations gratuites au numérique de
1h30 à 3 heures il est de notamment les
participants à utiliser leur ordinateur
leur boîte mail ou encore leur
smartphone d'autres ateliers peuvent
aussi être organisée en fonction de la
demande comme mettre en forme son cv ou
se familiariser avec d'octo libre
prochaine étape poissy du 27 juin au 9
juillet et si les travaux ont pris un
peu de retard la cathédrale de
versailles devrait bientôt retrouver de
son éclat l'horloge a été réparé le
grand orgue et restaurer les vitraux
sont en cours de finition les fidèles
pourront retrouver la cathédrale de
saint louis d'ici cet été
c'est la fin de cette édition spéciale
jeux olympiques 2024 merci de votre
fidélité merci également à patrick
jacques de dixmude qui était derrière la
caméra avec moi sur cette journée au
vélodrome cette émission est bien sûr un
revoir en replay sur notre site internet
et notre application mobile belle soirée
sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]